so when it comes to staying informed
about the pandemic we we are getting
very different messages from different
messengers and we have a new poll that
has very quickly talent told us that
Donald Trump is not one of the most
trusted messengers for the American
people although his approval rating is
actually up and I'm going to talk about
that seeming incongruity in a moment it
may not surprise you that New York
Governor Andrew Cuomo and dr. Anthony
Fauci who's one of the top infectious
disease experts in the country he's been
a fixture of at least some of trumps
press briefings they are the most
trusted people for guidance on the
pandemic and the poll asked when it
comes to official advice regarding
coronavirus please rate how much you
trust the following messengers on a
scale from one to five of course a
higher number being more trusted dr.
Anthony Fauci
at the top at three point eight four
followed by Andrew Cuomo at three point
two nine dr. deborah birx close behind
at three point one democratic California
Governor Gavin Newsom at two point nine
seven followed by Joe Biden then Mike
Pence and Donald Trump is trusted only
more than Stephen minuchin so it looked
to put it a different way only Stephen
minuchin is less trusted when it comes
to coronavirus than Donald Trump so I
have a few different thoughts on this so
on the one hand there's no question that
of course vouch Ian Cuomo are more
trustworthy than Donald Trump that's the
reality it's good that the polls reflect
that the other side of it is though the
numbers should be far more stark I mean
the degree to which Anthony Fauci and
Andrew Cuomo present facts and live in
the real world compared to the degree
with which Donald Trump is living in a
fantasy world with just lies and
distortions you would hope that the
numbers were more than you know a 1
point something points apart but let me
talk about the other side of this for a
second because Donald Trump's approval
rating is up the portion of the
population that believes Donald Trump is
handling coronavirus properly is quite
high it's much higher than anyone who's
been paying attention in a real way
would expect it to be and so it seems
like there's a disconnect there how can
Donald Trump be so not trust
when it comes to the specifics of
coronavirus while at the same time he's
got the highest approval rating of his
presidency or at least tied with the
highest approval rating of his
presidency I don't think there's as much
of a disconnect there as some people
might think here's what's going on
it appears that on the facts most
Americans realize what Donald Trump says
about the virus is not accurate he's
either lying he's incompetent he doesn't
know he's being deceptive but at the
same time that Americans recognize that
we know that during national crises
there is a degree of a rally around the
president effect it's only a few points
of approval that Donald Trump has gained
and that's probably what explains it
Trump because of the rally around the
president mentality during a crisis in
this case a pandemic has gained a little
bit of approval there but on the facts
Americans realize that the guy's a
buffoon when it comes to coronavirus now
there's another issue that's probably a
factor in the United States we've got
very densely populated areas and very
rural depopulated areas right now it's
much more the densely populated areas
that are having the coronavirus cases
and the deaths so there are probably
lots of people who are saying I'm not
seeing many cases in my area I don't
know of anybody who's got it I'm not
hearing about death
so therefore Donald Trump must be
handling this well while simultaneously
realizing when they hear Trump speak
that on the facts of the day-to-day he
probably can't be trusted now when it
comes to doctor foul Chi there are more
and more questions about how long he's
going to be allowed to have a public
presence because he doesn't seem
completely on board with every idiotic
thing that Donald Trump says although
there's some limit to how much he can
express that that disagreement publicly
there's no doubt that despite Donald
Trump saying two days ago when he was
asked is everything okay with you and
dr. fowey he said of course of course of
course my if I found out in a few days
that foul Chi was gone or resigned it
would not be a huge surprise I'm not
saying I expect it to happen but it
would not be surprising could be a
combination of you know Trump gets very
jealous people seem to like and trust
doctor foul Qi much more as we see from
this poll Trump's not going to like that
additionally doctor foul Qi I can't
imagine is going to say let's let her
rip on April 12 that could create a
point of conflict
it wouldn't be shocking to me if we
never see doctor foul Qi again at least
with Donald Trump after a few days
lastly let me talk about Donald Trump's
daily press conferences there's a
growing debate over whether corporate
media should should or shouldn't cover
the daily coronavirus press conferences
from Donald Trump because on the one
hand Donald Trump is using them to
spread disinformation he's telling lies
he's cheerleading his handling of
coronavirus on the other hand it is the
president speaking about a national
emergency and a pandemic so what should
corporate media do so this is not to Pat
myself on the back because lots of
people are doing this what corporate
media should do is to in real-time fact
check Donald Trump you've got to be
ready when Trump says things about
testing we've tested more people than
anyone we say we have 340 million people
on a per capita basis that's not true
and that's what matters when Donald
Trump says GM is making ventilators we
point out and we say no GM is making a
list of parts they would need and
figuring out where they would get the
parts
that's what GM has done so far GM is not
making ventilators I don't know that
corporate media is willing to do it
because they will take heat from the
right if they do that that would be the
responsible way to cover Donald Trump's
press conferences and publicly push for
Trump not to be a part of them say we
just want to hear from the doctors and
the public health experts that's what
they should do I wouldn't expect them to
do it